vlad's here because we're going to begin
this hour with some of the biggest
parenting questions out there for new
parents in particular it's all part of
our vlad's dad Series where we help our
very own Vlad two ta love these Graphics
uh figure out how to prepare for
fatherhood I'm a father of four posted a
picture yesterday of myself a memory a
day I don't even remember at all I'm
carrying a rocker a bottle of wine a
baby a binky a baby wrap I got it all
you got a pacifier in your mouth total
blur I've forgotten as much about parody
I have no recollection of that night it
looked like I had fun though
early days of parenting can truly be a
blur I mean no joke about it but it's
good to be prepared and we've got some
help on that front pediatrician Diane
Hess is with us to help answer some of
vlad's questions and some questions from
viewers who are new parents as well
welcome good to see you Dr Hess so Dr
Hess and I have spoken many many times
on CBS News streaming so it's good to
have you in person in the studio so
um let's talk about the things that I I
brought some pictures in to show okay
which makes me wonder how we all
survived to get to this point here
because there are so many things you
need to be concerned about look at this
little very crappy changing table that I
was on it looks like an ironing board
right look at this this is my little
sister in her crib look at that plastic
all around what I know right all this
stuff and look at that little crappy
like car seat and the kid random kid on
the floor on the blanket right so
how you know doctor has there are so
many things that parents need to be
concerned about cribs like that have
bumpers in them what should parents keep
in mind when they're preparing so for
safe sleep they should be on a firm
mattress with a tight fitted sheet and
no bumpers no bumpers no stuffed animals
now you can't have anything in there
right you can't have anything in the
carpet if you look like in Finland and
you look up baby box in Finland they
send the babies home like in a little
box with like a very very thin thin firm
mattress so um then parents will say
what about a breathable filters but uh
bumpers breathable bumpers but what
happens is that it's a Suffocation
Hazard they can get their neck trapped
between the bumper and the bars so then
the parents say oh if I don't put a
bumper their arm will get stuck or the
Lego gets it oh but they'll survive they
won't yeah uncomfortable for a few hours
but they'll be fine and you put the baby
to sleep on its back which is the
opposite
yeah I was on my stomach right and
you're supposed to wrap them up they
look like little burritos that's an
option so like we don't ever I always
say we don't learn about swaddling in
medical school it's more of a nursing
thing but babies do like to be some
babies like to be swaddled some babies
you know we're in the uterus with their
arms up and they want to be with their
arms up when they come out so they you
could swaddle their legs or you can just
put them in a sleep sack I think I
didn't want to why babies we put them in
like two layers of pajamas one one with
feet and one without feet or something
like that but that's a parental choice
but you have to remember to unswaddle by
four months old or else they don't roll
over because they can't they can't learn
their motor skills because they're so
tight so there's like always pros and
cons and then with swaddling also we
have like a whole epidemic of flat heads
on their back because they're lying on
their back all the time so I always say
it is
in other countries in some countries
that's considered like cosmetically very
nice actually but um well let me ask you
one other thing that my doctor
um when we were meeting with her she
asked that everyone that comes to meet
the baby for the first time be fully
vaccinated including having uh whooping
cough vaccines and flu vaccines
um do you agree with that what I say is
that the people are going to spend a lot
of time with your newborn so if it's
going to be a grandma and a babysitter a
nanny a night nurse any of the people
who are you can't I don't know that you
can ask a friend to get a friend shot
right yeah I would ask them you know
we're used to wearing masks now if
you're not you know please wear a mask
right you know and anyway right now with
flu RSV all these viruses going around
you wouldn't be wrong to ask somebody to
put a mask on when they're visiting your
baby if you feel uncomfortable like I
always say like you're giving them the
the opportunity to meet your baby your
baby doesn't know the difference but if
your baby gets RSV or flu now that's
like a big deal right yeah we have some
viewer questions this is from Kristen
who asked great question thank you for
asking this question because I find this
so freaking irritating with my own
favorite daughter Kirby you had a baby
Luca a sleep training yes what is the
best because it used to be when when
they were born you put them in the bed
after they eat when they right then when
they cry pick them up now they have to
have a specific schedule we're killing
ourselves to get to Lucas Special
Special schedule for sleeping why can't
we just get them up when they cry and
wake up put them down when they're tired
now they have to have a schedule okay
but the schedule is different from the
training the training is about
overnights right no no no some people
have a schedule the whole day yeah so
they're very different I had that house
Tony where you had a second yeah all
right so what do you what do you feel
like that's really parenting style so I
I always say there's just not one size
fits all I'm a very relaxed person I'm a
very relaxed physician so I work with
that family so if you're a very type a
mom like your daughter who likes a
schedule I will work with you to make
that work sometimes I feel like these
families focus on minutia and because
they're so rapid sleep training only if
you want it only if you want it what
does it do how does it work yeah
some people do the Ferber method where
you go in the first night your baby
cries and you're going every five
minutes and you don't speak to them you
just Pat them and you don't say Mommy's
here Daddy's here because then you're
like engaging the enemy and they're like
oh you're here it's you know it's party
time just Pat them and walk out so the
first night you go in every five minutes
then the next night you go in every
seven minutes then every nine minutes
and then 20 minutes and then it sounds
extinguished right or you do cry it out
where like especially like in New York
City you tell your neighbors I'm doing
crying out my baby's gonna cry a few
nights and buy a new bottle of wine and
we're gonna let them cry it out but
there's different stages where you would
do that I don't recommend sleep training
before four months because I really
that's the question I think babies need
to be fed more often I would say Vlad
the people that do sleep training swear
by it I will say that they swear I still
don't understand what's the ultimate
goal to get your baby to sleep through
the night yeah
what are you trying to accomplish here
the dream is a 7 P.M bedtime 7 A.M wake
up for a baby under the age of one that
is you are lucky you have to remember
breastfed babies wake up one time a
night until they're one year old so what
might be right for one baby is not right
for every baby you know okay real quick
when should uh you start solids for you
so if you're a breastfed baby we usually
say starting solids at six months and if
you're a formula fed baby you can
introduce them between four and six
months but usually they don't have the
motor skills for it so it's usually
between five and six months where they
can really hold their head up be in a
high chair and enjoy it because they
look at you when you're eating and you
think that they're ready to eat but then
you give them the food and it's kind of
like a cat like they lick it and they
don't really know how to swallow it but
it's so cute but um for all babies now
we say that they should be exposed to
nut Butters and uh earlier peanuts
remember peanuts are a legumes you you
know explosive natural peanut butter and
then maybe almond butter or cashew
butter because we want to prevent the
allergy